i had to be more than 50 years old
to experience that moment of healing
this to me is the advantage
that writers have with every passing
year
how does a writer find defining moments
in their own life
kathy and i have developed a kind of a
list of characteristics that we think
describe defining moments and that they
help us
when we go looking for defining moments
so that list includes things like the
moment a dream was born it could be the
moment a dream died
sometimes defining moments or moments of
birth or death
and that can be a
a literal death
or it could be a figurative death the
death of a business
the death of a relationship
or the birth of a relationship
we think about
moments of discovery
so
for a child who's been adopted the
moment they discover that they were
adopted might
redefine their understanding of
themselves
a special kind of discovery is a lesson
that's learned so dorothy in oz
makes the discovery that there's no
place like home
and that discovery becomes the mantra
that allows her to travel back to kansas
it was the discovery that she needed
when she set out from kansas
she didn't think that the people at home
were special enough to cherish
she thought that real life
lay somewhere out there
and
along the way she makes the discovery
that there's no place like home and that
redefines who she is
sometimes we're looking for a moment
when
uh
a wound
was suffered uh or a loss was incurred
other times
we're looking for a moment of
the birth of hope or
a moment of healing a moment of
deep
emotional
or spiritual change
and
with that
it's not a checklist but that
those categories we can look at our own
lives and say well
um
what was a moment of deep emotional
change
that i've experienced if i'm a morose
person
was i always that way
and if not when did that change
kathy uh
found a
an old black and white picture of her
dad uh when he was a young boy
and kathy's dad
as i knew him was a serious mechanical
engineer
and
um not
not playful that's the last word i would
use for him and yet this picture
showed this impish kid with this like
wicked smile on his face
and
kathy and her brother turned to each
other when they found this picture and
said did you know that person
and they both said
no i never met that guy
well
what was the moment
when he went from
the playful imp
to
the
very serious
very dour
person that
my wife grew up with
that
at least turns our gaze in the right
direction
and we can start looking and see seeing
is there
is there a moment like that
now there are times i think that
we can't find the moment
either because it happened
when we were so young that we have no
memory of it
or it may be so traumatic
that
we have not allowed ourselves to
remember it
but we know we walk with the limp
and i discovered in myself
a
sort of evidence of a wound
that i don't ever remember suffering
but i remember as far back as six years
old having
having the damage
and so i don't know what that defining
moment was i just know that it exists
and i know that i learned from that
experience that i must not
let people
know the real me or they would not want
me
i learned that men are dangerous
and
i had to
i have no memory that accounts for those
things but i had to
look at that
history nonetheless and recognize those
lies as being so deep in my
in my firmware
that
i couldn't remember a time where they
weren't there and then i had to
i had to learn
the truth
that would neutralize those lies
and
i still feel like those lies are true
but i now know they're not and i'm able
to tell myself
here's the truth
there are people who actually know you
and they actually love you
and so the lie that if people know you
they won't love you that's a lie no
matter how
how that feels
and i've learned i'm not a little little
boy anymore and i don't have to be
afraid of grown-ups
uh it's not actually dangerous to have
human encounters even though it still
feels dangerous to me
well so i've just described a moment of
healing
that's also a defining moment
i had to be more than 50 years old
to experience that moment of healing
this to me is the advantage
that writers have with every passing
year
we keep getting more and more life
experience and so we have more and more
to draw on
if you're 20
well you've been through middle school
so you have
you know you've come through at least
one war that's painful yes and so
um you know i always think of the
popular kids i i i'm not sure they exist
i i haven't met anyone as an adult who
says oh yeah i breezed through eighth
grade it was awesome my favorite year
it's it's just awful
but
a 20 year old is going to have 20 years
of life experience
a 40 or a 50 or a 60 year old writer is
going to have
more life experience and so
while
the industry may have a preference you
know for 22 year old writers because
it's exciting
like it's exciting to get a new sports
car
mostly we give awards out to people with
a little more mileage on them
and it's because
in part
of
the greater life experience which gives
you more access to
these kinds of moments
you know you just jogged my memory
because i knew someone who was
considered very popular and they worried
their worry was they thought hey
everyone thought they were stuck up
and b they were worried about their
image and when they left the house how
did they look to everybody so to them
that was a huge concern because they
were afraid of breaking that image
and to me i saw the person as had it all
together and they had all these people
around them that wanted to be around
them but they were terribly concerned so
i guess you're right that to them it was
still tragic
i i do think about um
[Music]
people whose faces are on magazine
covers and
um there is a burden
that goes with that now we might think
oh you know boo hoo you're you're
beautiful and famous
but
um
there is a
there's a burden that goes even with the
popularity that that rises to the level
of celebrity uh of
an acquaintance once said to one of my
children
you don't know how hard it is to be so
pretty
and at the time i thought
that's a line i need to put in a script
but you know as you
as you
talk i think no that actually
for
for this young lady
she experienced that as
as pain and anxiety and
um
all of
all of that kind of human experience is
interesting to me both as a human but
also as a storyteller that's an
interesting character
it's not that wasn't my life experience
but um
it's it's an experience that's
interesting to me
is there a limit on how many defining
moments someone can have in their life
you know i've been thinking a lot lately
about defining moments and
uh
i keep discovering more of them
for myself
i'm not sure that the half dozen is any
sort of absolute limit at all i
you know i think that
our lives
don't continue in a straight line
there are reversals
there are moments of transformation our
lives
seem to unfold kind of in chapters
we don't just do the same thing the same
way
forever
well the whole world with
covid has experienced that that
things actually change
sometimes quite dramatically
so
um
i could probably put my finger on a
dozen
[Music]
moments that
from my own life that are pretty
profound
and create
distinct moments of before and after
so i don't know that there's an absolute
limit
um i just think that
practically speaking when we come to
characters
we probably want
to work with a manageable number of them
so that we don't dilute
their
impact and their power
especially if we're thinking of a
stand-alone feature film if we're
talking about a television series that
goes for many many episodes
then
you probably could
do justice to a dozen defining moments
over
you know 100 episodes if anybody
is doing 100 episodes anymore
at some point it um
uh you know
aristotle talked about um how many acts
there should be in any
any play
and he said well it just depends how
long the play is um
because an act
has to do with a reversal
and
there he says there should be a big
reversal
in each act
a life that is nothing but reversal
starts to feel
not like a real life
it would be like a football game where
there was an interception or a fumble on
every play it just becomes absurd
but
he says you've got to have enough of
them to keep it interesting
so that's his formula he doesn't tell us
you know how many acts there should be
in a one-hour television pilot
but the general principle is there
should be enough to keep it interesting
but not so many that it becomes absurd
and i suppose the same could be said of
defining moments